-Our next guest is the host of
the weekly web series
"Snugglestorm" that can be
found on his Instagram.
Here's one of our favorites,
the very funny Pete Lee.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Aww! Thank you so much.
It feels so good to be
back here in Minnesota.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Minnesota.
Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah.
Here, let me scooch past you.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, you better watch out
for that frostbite.
It'll burn you like a bagel.
Yeah.
This is my wardrobe
for the evening.
I wore a camouflage jacket.
Yeah, this is my woodsiest top.
But I don't know if you guys can
tell by the shiny zipper.
It's Lululemon.
Yeah, I look like a dance mom.
I look like I should have
a chest tattoo of a Crock-Pot...
with potholders that say,
"Live, laugh, love."
Oh, it just feels so good to be
around people again.
Do you guys agree with that?
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh!
I've been so lonely in COVID,
the other day,
my Bluetooth speaker was like,
"Ready to connect,"
and I was like, "Ah, me too."
I want to connect with people
that don't even want to
connect with me.
I met my new neighbor
the other day.
He's this burly biker dude.
He goes, "What's up?
My name is Chainsaw Mike."
Yeah, and I didn't want
Chainsaw Mike to think
that I didn't also have
a scary Nickname.
So I was like, "What's going on?
My name is Indoor Dining Pete.
Yeah, I'm dangerous.
I touch door handles
and everything."
I touch door handles,
but I touch them up top now.
That's what I do.
Right? I Michelle Obama
the door handle.
Yeah. Other people go low.
I go high.
But now, when I enter
into a restaurant,
I look like a stripper
who's starting her dance.
Like, I don't just enter.
I create an experience.
And then, when I leave,
you know, I wipe it down.
[ Imitates hissing ]
God.
Oh! Have you guys seen this show
on TV called the news?
Oh, my God.
It is the best season ever.
Wow!
I saw this thing
on the news that said
that if you just load up
on vitamin D,
you're basically bulletproof
to COVID.
And I believe everything that
I see on the news.
This lady sneezed right next
to me the other day.
She was like, "Ah-choo!"
I went tanning.
Yeah. I walked out of there,
I was like, "It's a tan-demic."
But look at me. I'm not tan.
I'm like a shade of pink.
Like, look at my rosy
Santa cheeks, you know?
Like, if somebody was like,
"What's your ethnicity?",
I'd be like,
"Uh, Himalayan sea salt?"
Pretty sure.
But my favorite character
on the news is Bernie Sanders.
I love him. Yeah. Oh, my God.
I love him so much because
I'm a late sleeper,
and he looks like he is, too.
But I just love the way that
Bernie Sanders talks.
Have you guys
ever heard him talk?
Here's what it sounds like when
Bernie Sanders talks.
Have you ever rolled luggage
over a brick walkway?
That's what it sounds like.
Like, "Da-da-da-da.
Da-da-da-da!
We need healthcare for all.
Da-da-da-da-da.
The wealthiest 1%.
Da-da-da-da-da-da."
Alright, thank you guys so much.
You've been a wonderful crowd.
Thank you very much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-My thanks to Tracy Morgan for
being here in studio!
We love you, Tracy!
Sam Heughan, Pete Lee,
and The Roots right there,
everybody.
Thank you for watching.
Stay safe, everyone.
Stay tuned for
"Late Night with Seth Meyers."
Good night, everyone.